Now, I'm going to show
you some pseudo code for
how you might implement this API for
a linear regression learner.
So we define our class as LimRegLearner.
And this first method init with
underscores on either side
is the constructor.
The constructor is really easy.
For the linear regression learner,
we actually don't have to do anything
when we instantiated
an instance of the learner.
So we just use pass,
which means do nothing.
Our training method takes an x and a y,
and remember, x can be multidimensional.
And what it's doing,
it should take this x data and
this y data and fit a line to it.
So it's trying to find an m and a b.
So the job of the train method is
to find that linear equation or
the parameters for
that linear equation, m and b.
So here on the left-hand side,
we have self.m which means the m
goes to the local instance,
and b to the local instance, and
you're allowed to use any number of
linear regression algorithms at your
disposal as part of SciPy and NumPy.
So go Google and
find which one you want to use here and
just stuff it's output into m and b.
Finally, query is passed in x and it's
supposed to predicted y given that x.
And remember,
this is potentially a list of x's and
it can also be multidimensional.
Anyways, it's very simple.
You just multiply that x times m and
add b and return y, boom, that's it.
In short, this is literally how
short your LinRegLearner can be.
Now, the k and
n API is going to look exactly the same.
And the reason for that is if we have
the same API, we can easily mix and
match, and try training and
querying with the different
algorithms and see how they compare.
Okay, that is it for regression.
I'll see you at the next lesson.
Have a great day.